[Music]
[Music]
for virgins Palm Springs California
oh and can we make shopping do your OB
both parents um I grew up with my mom
and stepdad my two younger brothers my
half-brothers and then I left my mom's
when I was teenager moved in with my
father going to high school my two older
brothers and until I graduated and which
I graduated in the Arizona and you
started working right away mad out of
school work out where you do others in
restaurant business pasta same serving
um yeah I did
um you know sometimes that high school
you don't go to parties start smoking
weed and drinking a lot you know and
then I got back senior year really
didn't party too much and then I got in
high school and just stopped working and
then my off days after a couple years I
was working wasn't right away I you know
started using and more and more of us on
the weekends and then get time off and
go out of town and then party then also
this is all sorts of food anger right
you meet different people are you go
hang out was enough to work or or
whatever and they want to you know here
trying to conquer you know I mean or
contrast next to see you know and it's
all there they want to pay for it so
I was I mean I was like to try
everything heroin that's it
but more relaxed you know
I never tried it as something sweet from
anything I was depressed and going
through a lot of emotional pain and it
just felt like I was always angry and
just not doesn't feel right like that's
being me like more more like I needed
something but I really have friends and
it's something that I don't feel better
after you know like you're normal you
wake up every day and you have your
routine and then but yeah I just would
wake up and just be sad and angry and
then I'm gonna do anything no energy so
I'm I tried it one day and I really
liked it
[Music]
yeah exactly but you know
I stopped started again stopped started
I'm insulted cocaine
more than a few times while they were at
least 10 times you know crack and shiny
handful of times those are all definite
social social critics really but like I
said I went work towards a heroin
relax type of person math yeah I tried
that sometimes I do heroin into Kristen
math you know right after yeah some
people I was around didn't you certainly
just you know I do different things
hustle that's what they would call a
right swing so speakers hey we're here
today in the streets um you know long
and short of it prostitution you know
unfortunately it is illegal it's
actually you know really something you
think about and you know I don't know I
thought about it before like and I kind
of get so take jack [ __ ] like other
women to that or you know people always
talk to him like that's the lowest of
low you can go as far as a job or
degrading yourself as a woman and I just
think like well I mean if you're safe
you wear protection right and I mean to
do it all the time it's one thing but to
do it I guess when you need it for
certain things is another that's what I
found myself
having to turn to it at times because
you know I'm not here by myself
I don't know anybody you know and I'm
hungry and people don't just give you
anything money they I mean it's I like
here it's the hardest ever anywhere I've
ever been in my life
it took me two or three days I think
those two days to get a dollar one
dollar out here seriously being totally
normal you know not even messed up okay
and it was really hard and people want
to let me use their cell phone or
nothing
I'm just saying this is really gonna get
bad but point is is that you know I go
out there and it's 20 25 bucks for
sexual intercourse you know and you
don't know if they're a cop you don't
know what they're up to and it's scary
you know I've had a gun to my head
threatens to even use without protection
and that's one of my biggest fears it
happened and there we threw a little
loop you know I just taught me I got a
budget my money
when I do get it you know as far as
partying and things like that but I get
money every month I get and come from
welfare right but you know make it so
much so there's 30 days in a month and
you know at some point you're addicted
you need a fix you'll resort to others
resort to you know I've seen people
robbery I people came up and robbed me
you know right away I mean I asked me to
go make that money and I don't even know
I have and I've gotten out of a car late
straight up Rodney just took my money
and I felt those people I got the car
they know I have money so that's my
stuff know if I gotta do it again I
don't know who's around or if I'm gonna
get right
my money I'll get it up or who knows
what will happen so it's very scary it
is yeah
so you just got to be careful I try not
to go sorts of that I don't have you
know
but it's scary sleeping you would tend
to though you know by yourself I don't
know you heard about shootings and sorry
to say it murders and hit and runs and
things like that that happen all the
time on these streets on the next block
and next block like it's everyday event
yeah Wow
it really makes you think what an area
you know any means right it's just yeah
and it's just like and you know it's
people you literally run into or talk to
you're just like well you know and it's
one day you see somebody the next day
you know wrong place wrong time I was in
the tent
she's me cleaning a tent and they ever
come here they did a sweep and they came
in and they just walked right in the
tent
and they found things in the tent they
weren't mine but I couldn't prove it
wasn't my time because I may have ID or
anything on me right and the owner
wasn't there so they said well
one who's accountable and I said oh my
god that's unbelievable I don't have a
record out no way and I said well we're
gonna get your name I don't know what
it's they found baggies of powdered
substances they have to test that myself
to go to court but they tell me what
they are they say it's meth possession
of meth possibly cocaine I don't know
weapons and night needles all sorts of
things and I I can't find it because I
have nothing else to prove so they are
they're not together my biological yeah
they do they do I don't keep in touch
with them as much as I used to and
they're not here almost eight months
[Music]
I do but being out here it's a lot
harder you know any mean I can't commute
back and forth like one and that's out
there was a lot easier because it was
done just a couple blocks away but out
here obviously it's a lot harder I've
attempted to go back a couple times
right by Kenny Reitz it just didn't work
out and then getting a bus ticket and
then lost my ID right or it got stolen
doing it again and then I misplaced it
so it's a process all over again to get
back but I can take the bus and get back
but I'm here going through all that I've
gone through with James out the welfare
system here does
and help the homeless a lot more than
anywhere else I've been even though I
haven't been hold us anywhere else but
so they're offering help out here to
bend myself with job employment and
things like that so I'm gonna take it up
and continue myself out here and the
better end of the spectrum you know see
what I can do with that but like I said
it's still a struggle I don't know what
tomorrow is gonna bring her the next day
or the next day so it sounds all good
but I don't really know until it happens
right no he's just always look important
when am I gonna see him next you know I
don't like the fact when I'm the EP
cries you know it's sad you know he's
there because I I moved away to find
more stable environment a different
environment all together right but
unfortunately in doing so it backfired
as my parents are like well now that
you're out there and you're running
around everywhere you know because I
don't have an exact plan right they feel
them unstable so now they're making it
harder for me to try to get my son back
right which I get it but now looks like
they've lost all trust in me being is
that I'm out here and they don't know
everything that's going on they kind of
turned it on me a little bit when I'm
out there and you know I'm starting my
day and I'm hungry
I have no other resources or money and
I'm thinking okay well what am I gonna
do to eat uh-huh I mean I smoke
cigarettes how am I gonna do that fifty
cents a cigarette or whatever they
definitely don't give them to you then
it becomes like I feel I want nicotine
okay or you know I don't really feel
good today I know that I'm gonna check
these type of people if I use unity
that's gonna bring in more money okay
okay well you know what
I don't feel T great I think I need to
go get some more crystal I'm gonna go
get some more
I feel a lot better well this person is
around I gotta go to this first to me
that's what it cost 20 more dollars well
great
okay so no no that's the food on top of
the fix or on top of whatever I'm gonna
buy right and then cigarettes - that's
plenty of any money so now it's not only
one person it's another person that's
what two or three people to try to you
know look looks apart and give myself
out or whatever about you know and being
convincing I'm not gonna rob them and
they're not gonna hurt me so it's also
place a part of me as a woman being
degraded and you know actually I've had
time from during intercourse a guy is
actually climbing how do you feel
training yourself doing the lowest job
lowest type of work you could do as a
woman and I'm just like serious you know
I'm sitting there like I want you to
enjoy yourself and they know they were
paying for it and it's wrong but
like this what you say why do you need
to survive and he said totally enjoying
putting me out and say wow no yeah it is
hard because like are you serious
of all things to talk about or you know
and that really kind of hurt me but I
can't show that right right right
and I'm just like like you know I'm not
good enough to do it right or they're
not answer me or they're trying to get
something out of it right so or
something you know any reason or they
say oh I will no offense I was raised in
a house with all women or I've been
around I've worked these streets for
years so I know what it's like if you're
a freak excuse me if you're inferior
work and I think they're just playing me
so you know I don't even want to pay
it's not worth my time
oh really not to like what an hour
already
you don't mean you made me do all these
different things no I'm just not into it
you know you know so I want to get
really mad and lash out but I don't you
know and then I saw money and what do
you do
it is and it's very hard definitely D
twice with decisions and mm-hmm it is it
is because I haven't completely found
myself and what I'm truly happy doing oh
I have 32 I am but I feel a lot older
you know I don't feel that's why I says
I should be you know like I haven't
taken in all that all that I've learned
and applied it correctly to my life get
that in time I will all right thank you
thank you